[Music]
so here what it says core of webdriver
automation framework without proper
design your test may look like the image
below if you don't
think and you know without any design
you may end up by saying login test
product test Add to Cart s check out
tests check out test payments check out
this shipment payment test and payment s
and etc it may be possible that the
things which you are using here might
can be used in product tests as well it
might be possible there whatever the
things which you are doing here can be
used and Add to Cart as well
these are the things which we are going
to use now length is C this key with
page object you are creating one object
for sign-in page product list one object
got one object shipment one object
payment one object order one object when
you are using the login test when you
are creating select product test it
might be using sign-in page objects as
well as product list object so it may be
possible like I have shown you just now
in the trivago in that we were using
multiple pages multiple page objects and
we were coming up with the test case and
that's what it is showing us in a form
for diagram if you want you can go
through the back but this is all we are
you going to write our permission claim
book and that's what it states
consideration whenever you create page
object design always consider these few
things always
create a class for every web page
create a class for every web page web
page elements web page elements are
instance variables of pages a class of
type of element what it's saying that
whatever the elements you will be going
to write in that are always instance or
always instance variable we will be
going to do that service page would
include sign-in page act card
which becomes a method in which object
class
so there will be services pages where
you may see sign in page add to cart
page Add to Cart query functionality or
methods I will say and then at the last
we have written in tests you create
object of page like us and call the
methods so let's go with three more
slides there are will quote with an
unusal design pattern test does not have
any technical code too complicated deal
with the browser so test will not have
any technical code okay make sure that
at whatever you are writing technically
you will be writing in the pages test
called page subjects and verifies the
result test is more readable like I've
shown you it was more readable form
their subject do not verify page load we
don't verify whether the page loaded or
not okay but they communicate with the
browser these are the syntax is what I
have mentioned here if you see here they
are using way dot uh till long but is
again also in the culture you can ignore
that again
okay let's just take a look at this
because all these syntax is is what we
are going to see
our cookie bake but let's take a look
these are the best practices one can
follow to make design robust and
maintainable create one page object
class for each per page
create it one page object class for each
web page okay we'll be doing that each
page object method should either return
the object on that page or should return
the page object of the next page we will
see it is this is what we call as in the
layman language linking between the
classes linking between the classes each
page objects should sell query date
whether the page is fully loaded before
giving control to the next step n theta
used by the page object should be passed
through test and should not be
hard-coded so now will not be hot
pudding anything and that's what here it
is showing us a very small example with
a patron sig BMI calculator and the test
and here again but
let me just create an architecture of
the framework and then we will
see all the things we'll be going to
execute
this is my test I will be going to
create few packages inside it and I will
be going to tell you about each package
everyone has a different way to define
it and this is how I always define some
people see it as page package but I call
it as core package this core package in
this core package I will be going to
initialize all my elements
in this this is the heart of the package
if something goes wrong in this package
in this whatever I will define in this
package if something goes wrong in that
nothing will get executed nothing will
be executed
second package
this is the package I am going to call
it as pages pages is here we will be
going to create all our pages means all
our classes for web pages so all the
pages are maintained right here
all of the package
will call it as
test cases Here I am keeping all my test
cases
another package
do tell here I'll be keeping all my
utilities
on the package
conflict here I'll be keeping all my
configuration pipes
another package
lost here I will be generating all my
logs related to my project
you
you
a new folder
let's do one thing instead of creating a
boulder let's use utilize those
resources and let's go here
one folder by the name of
drivers so all are Firefox Chrome I
drivers will be placed at this location
one more folder
test data
excel sheet or whatever test data you
are using you'll be putting your test
data right at this location
you
but more product
screenshots it said the project level
all the screenshot will be maintained in
this folder and
this is the architecture of my framework
which will I I'll be going to create
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here